The solution for the drinking birds crossbar and nose are nothing special. You
set the position. You rotate it by 90 degrees and you're pretty much done. The
eyes are a little bit more interesting. First you have to translate to position,
then rotate. To do this, you have to make an object 3D so that you can do the
rotation after the translation. Our drinking bird is functional but could always
be improved. He could maybe have a few helices for his tail feathers. His
eyeballs could be flatter and he could have pupils for his eyes. He could have a
jaunty hat and a corncob pipe in his mouth. The crossbar could surround his tube
instead of poking through it. He could have classier feet. I hope you'll play
around with him and improve his appearance. I'd love to see what you come up
with.